licensed professional
counselor and therapist who's worked for
decades in the field of mental health
first at community mental health
agencies and then in private practice
her research interests are in data
integration in health care and clinical
research
the use of geospatial data and health
care and clinical research the use of
geographic information systems in
healthcare and clinical research
psychometrics patient-centered care and
personalized medicine
so she uh today is defending her
dissertation
uh proposal i see that a few people have
turned their videos on and i've been um
encouraging people to do that although i
know sometimes people have um
reasons they can't and actually i'm
going to be entering a reason
like that in a moment so i'm going to at
least at the beginning of the talk turn
my video off but i encourage everyone
to keep their video on and when i can
put mine back on i will do so
so um i will turn turn it over to lily
thank you bill for that awesome
introduction and yes
it's helpful to me if you have cameras
on just so i don't feel like i'm
talking to my laptop here
um so let me
share my screen and
somebody might need to
pipe up if this does not
work as expected
okay so can you guys see my
we're seeing your view
oh okay that's not good
let me try that again
sorry
uh
okay
of course i have like a million slides
to get through too
okay now share
as
oh there we go
stop sharing let me see
what if i do
that and switch nope
i need to do different kinds of sharing
here
oh here we go
ah
success okay
so
welcome to my proposal defense um today
i'm going to talk about
data quality in the context of clinical
social determinants of health research
so the background here is that
earlier this year an article in jamia
outlined a new subfield of informatics
social informatics which is devoted to
the application of information
technologies to capture and apply social
data in conjunction with health data to
improve clinical care and advance
individual and population health
so what social informatics does is use
social determinants of health data from
informatics resources like
ehrs claims data
and mhealth data and it uses that to
inform research and enhance patient care
and social informatics rose from one of
the objectives in the nlm's most recent
10-year strategic plan
and that objective uh is to develop data
standards and processes for accessing
information and accelerating
standards for the social behavioral and
environmental aspects of health
in both amia and the nlm have been
emphasizing social determinants recently
because there's been an increased
understanding of just how much these
non-clinical factors and
contexts influence patient health
so social determinants data gets used
lots of ways
but one of its primary applications is
that it's used for
health equity research and the goal of
health equity research is to help us
better understand why people have
different health outcomes and also how
we can make sure that everyone has a
fair opportunity to attain their full
health potential
and now that we've been looking at and
using social determinants data more and
more frequently it's become more clear
that this data is often very messy and
we don't have many ways to tell if it's
good or any formalized ways to improve
it
and if we're not careful about the
quality of the data then we really can't
guarantee
that any research we perform with it is
yielding valid or useful insights
so this is an important issue because
poor data quality can cause problems
with bias reliability and
validity so my work intends to close
that gap by looking carefully at the
data quality issues that are specific to
social determinants of health research
and
delving into
the details of how those problems are
identified and addressed
so here's an example of what i mean when
i say that this data is often messy
and that can cause problems when we try
to use it for research so this is ohs
used kova 19 dashboard from the middle
of october
this was created by faiza khan at ohsu
and we know
that people of color are
disproportionately affected by covet 19
but we don't know exactly why that is
so if we're
uh
if we're investigating that issue and we
zero in
on just the part of the dashboard that
categorizes data about race race and
ethnicity
we can see that there's a significant
number of patients whose race is given
as unknown or declined in other words
there's a lot of missing and incomplete
data
and um
second race and ethnicity data is
self-reported by patients and the
distinction between race and ethnicity
is
usually confusing to patients and to
most people
so patients are choosing how to
categorize themselves but they don't
know what those categories mean because
the categories are confusing
so
for example are hispanic people
represented at all
in the case by race
area and if so where
so ohsu and other institutions that
collect and report this information
they've been working on being more
careful about how they collect it going
forward but
we still have to use this current data
set right and what can we do to make
that data more usable so we can figure
out how and why
people of color are more profoundly
affected by profit 19 right are they
being more severely affected because of
some genetic factor or is what we're
seeing here the result of something more
closely related to
income or occupation or maybe even
access to care
and those are important distinctions
because the two those two explanations
of why we're seeing this
they have very different recommendations
for how we can stop the spread
so because social determinants are these
non-clinical factors like race and
ethnicity and income and physical
environment
that means that we need to use
non-clinical data in order to build our
research data sets
and there are two ways to get that
non-clinical data and the first method
is to rely exclusively on information
about the patient that's just contained
within the ehr
um but these social determinants
information like
race and ethnicity and income levels and
exposure to environmental pollutants
that's either really sparsely collected
in the health record and or it's not
collected at all so pretty much all we
have in the ehr is limited to
demographic information
um
with some exceptions but what little
information we do have about social
determinants suffers from
data quality problems that are very
typical and secondary use ehr data right
so that's
because those are things you guys are
familiar with but that's things like
data that's missing or incorrect or
heterogeneous or sequestered in
unstructured text fields
and this article kind of highlights what
i'm talking about so the authors looked
at what which social determinants were
available in the hr
and they included they concluded that
most were not available or were only
very sparse and they tried using nlp to
pull additional information
from the structured text fields about
some of those
social determinants factors
and although nlp did find some
additional information it was really
quite modest improvement in what they
could find
but these
authors did find that around 95 of the
patients
had
zip code information somewhere in their
record
so even with nlp many social
determinants of health researchers find
it
too limiting to only use the ehr
as the only source of social
determinants data
but because we usually do have zip codes
from the patient record
that's where geographic information
systems can play a role because
researchers will oftentimes take the
data from the ehr
and use patient addresses to link that
health data with data from external
sources
usually that's data from the community
or the population level like
neighborhood data from
the u.s census
or air quality data from the epa
and linking data that way allows us to
get a much richer picture of the
non-clinical factors that influence
patient health
um
and incorporate these novel variables
into our clinical research
so social determinants research is
different from other kinds of secondary
use research
in that it's far more likely to utilize
this data linkage process and to utilize
external data sets
and when we're working with these
integrated social determinants research
data sets
what that means is that we've not only
got all of the error from the ehr data
but now we've compounded that with all
the error from the external data set
which means that bias and error can be
introduced as a result of bad data from
the patient record
badges facial address data bad data from
the external data set and sometimes all
three of those
so
we need to acknowledge and do something
about the fact that social determinants
data sets have a huge potential for
error and for data quality problems
um because as i found in my preliminary
work on wildfire this makes social
determinant studies more prone to type
one error which is a fancy way of saying
that it's really easy to lose the signal
and all of this noise when we're doing
research with social determinants data
and
the question is how do we solve that
problem
and how do we ensure that we don't lose
the signal and all the noise
so in health research
or informatics research like as in other
fields that rely heavily on data science
the work of this data quality assessment
and improvement it largely takes place
when we're
cleaning transforming and integrating
data so basically all the things that we
do
when we're preparing the data set for
analysis
um and as many of you know data
wrangling tends to be very time
consuming um
some research has even shown that it's
the lengthiest step of a quantitative
research project
and it also tends to be conducted in a
very ad hoc manner
while there are some general guides for
doing it
there aren't any that are specific to
social determinants of health research
and because this field of social
informatics is so new
there are very few if any protocols or
agreed upon methods
that are available to guide researchers
so again that means researchers take
this very ad hoc approach to data
quality improvement
and
which means that researchers will get
like wildly different results even from
the same data set so this as this
article and nature demonstrated so the
the authors of this article gave 29
different research teams the same data
set and the same research question which
was
are dark-skinned soccer players more
likely to get a red card than
light-skinned players
and they found that the findings from
the research teams varied a lot
as you can see here and because
these researchers use
such a
wide variety or grab bag and
methodologies that can also make it
difficult to judge the quality of the
research results right like
how do we know which of these results is
the right one or the best one
it also means that the
time and effort involved in data
preparation tends to be very steep
which can be a rate limiting factor for
research projects
right
it's harder to get them done get them
done quickly
and this ad hoc approach also really
impedes reproducibility
and medicine in general is already doing
kind of a poor job with reproducibility
compared to other scientific fields
as
this other article in nature showed
so to help resolve this problem i intend
to examine
the data quality needs of social
determinants of health researchers by
working to identify the data quality
problems requirements and assessment
methods that are specific to this
particular field of research and
in order to accomplish that i want to
pursue these three specific aims
um
and
all of these aims
are
basically a process that's building
towards developing a checklist
that will be in the checklist will be
the product of several studies right
um and the first study will be
literature-based and is intended to
characterize
the data quality specific to social
determinants of health research the
second study will be
very highly structured data-driven
descriptive case study that's intended
to look at the practicalities of
assessing and addressing data quality
issues
um and that case study will kind of
document a data quality improvement work
flow
that will ultimately inform the
checklist that i'm going to create with
my third aim so in the third and final
aim
i'm going to develop and refine an
exploratory solution
the checklist over several iterations
so
like i said these three aims are
intended to work together as an
iterative incremental process that
culminates in the development of a data
quality improvement checklist
that will help guide clinical social
determinants of health researchers
during the process
our improving data quality
will help reduce error and it will help
increase steady validity and reliability
and this iterative and incremental
development process has been used
in computer science
since the 1930s and it's kind of this
series of
plan do study act cycles that work
together
okay so i'm going to start here with my
first aim in this first aim um
i plan to conduct a systematic
literature review an approach i'm
planning to use is realist review
which is this theory driven deductive
and systematic review so realist review
is grounded in practice and it's focused
on testing the validity of
proposed solutions
and the primary advantage of realist
review is that it's mindful of how
theories can be applied
in certain contexts with a particular
emphasis on healthcare contexts
so the theory that i'm going to apply in
in this review
is the harmonized model of ehr data
quality which for some reason isn't
showing up on the top sorry about that
and the context is
social determined clinical social
determinants of health research
and this harmonized model is essentially
a terminology in a way to conceptualize
and define data quality issues and it
consists of these three major elements
conformance completeness plausibility so
completeness is like whether or not this
element is present um
plausibility is like whether or not this
element seems like it would be correct
and conformance is
more of a technical requirement like um
does this
does this element have conformed to the
values that we're expecting
so the goal of this aim
is to use that existing ehr data quality
framework the harmonized model to
conduct a review
of the literature
the social determinants of health
literature in order to identify and
describe the data quality needs specific
to clinical social determinants research
and the objectives are to extract
information from the literature
and the data quality issues that are
typically encountered during that
research process and then
categorize them using the harmonized
model
to see
and also to see if the data quality
issues and social determinants of health
research is similar to those found in
other secondary use research
so here are the steps that i plan to
take to fulfill this aim i'm not going
to read all these because i'm going to
detail them
um but first i intend to search for
articles focused
on
clinical social determinants research um
so articles that
also
incorporate elements of data accuracy
validity introduction of bias related
data quality terms because um
data quality is not a mesh term
but data accuracy is
and i've already consulted with andrew
hamilton to identify the ideal search
terms and search strategy
and he recommended using
a combination of pubmed
using the terms here and then an
adjacency search in avid medline
and here's the terms for
that adjacency search
um and i also want to use i e e e
explore and um
google scholar so i can find articles
from fields outside of medicine
and once this body of literature has
been identified i plan to import these
articles into endnote and then screen
them for relevance based on title and
abstract
and then use a snowball technique to
find any literature that i might have
missed
in that initial search and then
kind of use scopus to come through the
citations from that first round of
articles
and then repeat the process of gathering
and screening those
that second round of articles too
so articles will be excluded if they're
not in english if they're not original
research or if they pertain to social
determinants of health research that's
conducted without patient data i.e if
they're not from an ehr registry et
cetera
and information about the discarded
articles will be tracked and entered
into spreadsheet or database
and i'll give justifications for their
exclusion also and document that
um so my contingency plan if the number
of identified articles is low like less
than 50.
then i want to expand the search maybe
to include articles about social
determinants of health
that are not specifically focused on
data quality but maybe identify those
issues as a limitation of the research
okay so the next step is that i want to
appraise these articles according to the
elements of the
harmonized data quality model that i
showed you earlier and to do that i'm
going to use an extraction template in
qualtrics you can see here
and i want to use this template to
characterize the data quality
issues that are identified in each of
the articles
and then also categorize them according
to the specific social determinants
that they're examining right like are
they looking at race are they looking
environmental exposures etc
and once i've collected all of that
extracted information
i want to tabulate it into something
that looks roughly like this shell table
and then i want to aggregate and compare
that information
and see if i can identify any patterns
and what general generalizations i can
make
um and then
compare their results of these studies
against each other to see if they
validate each other
and
see if they agree um and i also am
particularly interested in
whether there are data quality issues
that affect research on the specific
factors right like is race or ethnicity
data particularly problematic
or is data about the physical
environment better than other types etc
and then i also want to make those
comparisons i talked about earlier about
comparing the findings
of other secondary use data quality
studies to see if social determinants of
health research is
similar to other types of secondary use
data
right now my plan is to extract and
process the data myself so i can get a
good feel for it but
if that's too time consuming then my
contingency plan is to involve other
students
in order to expedite that so
what i hope to have when i'm finished
with aim 1
is
a better understanding of the data
quality specific to clinical social
determinants research
right like which categories of data
quality are most problematic and whether
some social determinants variables are
more prone to certain kinds of issues
and then that will be used to inform the
data quality improvement checklist that
i intend to create for am3
so for aim2 2
what i want to do is demonstrate how
data quality issues are identified
assessed and addressed
during the actual
process of social determinants of health
research and i want to do that with a
case study
this aim or this case study will be an
in-depth
examination of the methods and workflow
that i used for a study already
conducted
and that i'm currently wrapping up and
with that study i examined the effect of
an environmental determinant of health
in this case wildfire smoke exposure on
patients with cystic fibrosis
and in that research project the outcome
of interest was severe pulmonary
exacerbations and for that
we pulled data from the cystic fibrosis
registry
and then i used patient zip codes to
link their health records
to community level information from air
pollution monitors
so on the right is a map that i made
that shows locations of all the air
quality monitors in oregon
and i did use that to figure out if
those patients had been exposed to
wildfire smoke and then see if there was
this there was a relationship between
wildfire smoke exposure and severe
pulmonary exacerbation and that work was
primarily epidemiological and i've
already written it up into a manuscript
that's ready for submission
but i want to be clear about the fact
that this
um
that first manuscript's not directly
part of my dissertation work
because what i want to do for aim2 is
look at the choices that i made in order
to improve the quality of that data set
that the dataset i used for that study
and look
carefully and in-depth at all the
decisions and show how they impacted the
research results
so my intention is to document the data
quality improvement pipeline from start
to finish and to map out not only what
the data quality problems were but more
importantly how they were addressed
and here are all the steps that i intend
to take to do that which i'm going to
detail on the following slides
so the final deliverable of aim2 will be
a detailed map
that documents the data cleaning and
transformation process and i intend to
structure that map
using an approach that's inspired by
fault tree analysis and this map will
document the actions that i took
when i was addressing the data quality
problems
within that particular data set
so while aim 1 is about identifying the
data quality it's typical for social
determinants data
and two
is a case study in how i identified them
and work to resolve them
and i want to use fall tree analysis
here because it's a form of root cause
analysis
that's often used in engineering and
sometimes in medicine epidemiology is a
way to
improve reliability and quality by
plotting out the process of decision
making and its consequences
so the first step towards creating that
map is to characterize
the social determinants data in the data
set
again using the harmonized model of the
ehr data quality that i talked about
earlier
and i want to look at all of the social
determinants variables that are
available in that data set and use
that the
harmonized model framework to
categorize those problems
so the topulated results will probably
look something like this although note
that this is a dummy table so these
numbers are
synthetic um
and you'll notice that in this table
there's a column listing the actions
that i took to transform the messy data
into clean data
right like whether i filtered the data
whether i corrected it whether i
inferred it for example
this bottom row here describes the age
data which has some elements
that could be characterized by the
harmonized model as implausible
right so this is a plot of the age data
which as you can see is roughly normal
but it does have this really long tail
here and i consider the presence of
these elderly patients in the dataset
implausible because
although the prognosis for people with
cystic fibrosis has improved it's still
unusual for that population to live
until
old age
so i consulted with the clinician i've
been working with
dr aaron trimble and he explained that
the cystic fibrosis diagnosis contains a
number of phenotypes and that the older
patients represent an unusual
far milder variant of the cystic
fibrosis
gene or genes essentially
what he told me is that those people
don't really have cystic fibrosis at
least not how we commonly define it
so i felt like it improved the validity
of the data to remove those patients
from the data set because they have this
unusual phenotype they're not really
representative of the cystic fibrosis
population and they're probably only
going to muddy the signal because
they're less likely to experience the
outcome of interest
they don't have as many severe pulmonary
exacerbations they're not as sensitive
to environmental triggers as the people
with
the more common cystic fibrosis
phenotype are
and the research data set does not
include phenotype information so i can't
remove everyone with that phenotype but
i can filter by age and get some of them
right so i removed those impossible
elderly outliers which reshapes the data
somewhat and then over here on the left
with the red arrow you can see we have
zero year olds
now
that seemed plausible to me because
in the past people weren't diagnosed
with cystic fibrosis until it starts
causing problems for them for example
like a child who isn't gaining weight or
has an unexpected respiratory crisis
and also i wanted to make sure that this
wasn't just
missing data that somehow got recorded
as null and then it accidentally showed
up as a zero rather than simply as
missing
so i again consulted with the clinician
i was working with and he told me that
it's definitely possible that there are
in fact
babies in the data set i.e zero year
olds because a couple of years ago we
started testing for cystic fibrosis at
birth so people with the diagnosis now
start start showing up in the registry
much earlier than they used to
but as neonates they can't have been
exposed to wildfire smoke
they haven't had the opportunity to have
a severe pulmonary exacerbation yet so
again they're not going to be able to
tell us anything about our outcome of
interest and they're really going to
only muddy any signal that might be
there so
part of the data quality improvement
process also included
filtering all the newborns out of this
data set
so
moving forward with aim2 once i've
documented all those decisions that were
made
about the data and why they were made
and how those choices affected the
validity of the data
and eliminated this unnecessary noise
then next i want to demonstrate
quantitatively
how those choices made
during that cleaning and transformation
how that improved the data quality
quantitatively and affected the final
research product
and i want to do that by comparing
results from
the statistical analysis
using those two data sets right the raw
data set and the cleaned data set so how
each step that i documented has
affected these final results um
so to do that i plan to run tests for
things like sensitivity and specificity
and normality and variable selection and
model fit
and for differences in distribution of
the variables and also
i want to calculate the relative change
of those tests before and after cleaning
and i want to compare these results
both purely in quantitative terms but
also in terms of
interpretability and generalizability
right so for example
a log transformation
might make the data more normal and
would represent an improvement from a
purely statistical standpoint but from a
clinical standpoint that transformation
would make the resulting model more
difficult to interpret
so here are the results of the original
univariate model before cleaning and
pre-processing or
really i just did enough cleaning so
that the analysis will actually run and
if you note that the results here
they're not statistically significant
and they have a pretty high deviance so
for aim 2 the final deliverable will
show
the data wrangling process that got me
from these numbers here basically the
raw data to this where you might note
the results are statistically
significant and the deviance of the
model is far lower so obviously there's
a lot of steps here
in that not just removing the outliers
from the age data but basically m2 will
be about documenting everything that was
necessary for this signal to emerge from
all of that noise
and the final deliverable for aim2 would
be this map that's inspired by fault
tree analysis
that would be
a far more detailed version of this here
but
where i start with this raw data set on
the lower left side including
that description of all the social
determinants variables that i created in
the earlier step that you saw on the
table
and i have this kind of series of logic
gates that show how the
data preparation decisions and um
and how that changed the resulting
statistical analysis
at each step um and the arrows
here sort of depict the data quality
assessment method
um and i should note that fault tree
analysis typically it works by
calculating the likelihood
of an outcome happening given each event
in the process but i'm
adapting it to instead show how each
decision
gradually changes the results
until
after a lot of cleaning and
pre-processing we get to the final
results
that are in the upper right hand corner
however
data munching includes a lot of steps so
i gave this a pretty significant chunk
of time on my timeline um
but if it takes
even longer than what i've set aside and
it's throwing off my schedule too much
then my contingency plan is to take
and maybe do this as like a higher level
overview and to simplify the issues into
much broader causes of data quality
problems like
um
maybe instead identifying how those
problems were introduced or looking at
correlates of data quality problems
oh right so that's what i plan to do for
aim2
i basically document this entire data
quality improvement pipeline and that's
once i have that in hand i want to use
that for my final aim
which is aim three
where i plan to
develop a checklist to cleaning
transforming and integrating data
in clinical social determinants of
health research
and to do that i want to
take that detailed map of data quality
of the data quality improvement process
then i will create a name to and then
generalize it into something that can be
used
more broadly for clinical social
determinants research of all kinds so
the target audience for this aim is
clinical researchers who are engaged in
social determinants research and
it's intended to be
cited like in the methods section
of their papers
this checklist
is meant to help improve the quality of
the data that's used in social
determinants research while also
encouraging reproducibility
and to develop this checklist i want to
use the
iterative incremental process that i
talked about earlier
and so the first iteration of the
checklist will draw upon a
well-established prior work
and the second iteration will adjust the
checklist based on
experience applying it to a real world
research project not the a different one
from the one i have already finished and
the third iteration will be based on
evaluations from potential
users
so for the first step i want to use this
foundational work
from rom and joe
on data cleaning
and
use that deliverable that i will create
in aim two
that whole detailed process with all the
data transformation steps and
adapt what ramando have done to the
specific needs of social determinants
researchers right so
ramando
outlined these phases that you see
listed here on the right data analysis
transformation
workflow
mapping rules etc
and i
want to use this
using this iterative incremental process
take
those phases
that they described and use them as a
scaffold to create the first iteration
of the checklist
right so use use what are the name two
and use that to adapt the phases to the
needs of clinical social determinants
researchers so the first iteration might
look something like this very
preliminary one here
um
right so for example if um
you
were doing social determinants research
and you wanted to make sure that you'd
be able to
um
stratify the data set by age for example
phase one of the data cleaning you might
wanna
check to make sure that all of the
data
is
type int or that
you create another column for
uh age categories or it might be
important in phase two to
standardize the race and ethnicity data
and make sure
that the data from people who identify
with more than one race for example is
all treated the same way because that is
typically a problem
that people encounter working with race
and ethnicity data so
that's how i want to create that first
iteration
and the second iteration
will be based on experience applying
this checklist
the first iteration of the checklist the
work of the
n3c social determinants of health data
quality project so i've been
participating in this group for the past
month
and it's a
group that
includes a lot of
very highly involved
experts
in social determinants and data quality
research and they recently started a
quality assurance team
so that provides me with this
mature
and really important use case on which
to refine
and test
this checklist that i want to create
and specifically i want to work with the
team
to prepare
publicly available data sets for
analysis
and work with them to create this data
quality
pipeline or
refine it
so i want to apply the checklist to this
work
observe how well it performs
revise it based on what
works well and what does not
and
um
my idea is to ensure that this checklist
is generalizable for use across
a variety of clinical social
determinants data sets
so the final iteration of this checklist
will be based on
feedback from
somewhere like five to six
experienced researchers um
and for that i plan on soliciting the
feedback of researchers using
semi-structured interviews and i want to
just have a handful of kind of
open-ended questions that are focused on
usability and i chose
usability
as the most important metric
first and foremost because i want this
checklist to be something that actually
gets used but also because
the operational definition of usability
is actually quite similar to that for
data quality right so um
john brooke when he introduced the
system usability scale
in 1996 he defined usability as
appropriateness for a purpose which is
exactly how
um
wang and strong defined data quality in
their landmark article that came out the
same year so usability i feel is a
really good metric because it
encapsulates a lot of the concepts that
are intrinsic to data quality
and my plan is to schedule interviews
with the researchers individually and
then
provide them
with the checklist like a week or so
prior to the interview and ask them to
examine it in advance um
and this semi-structured interview will
contain
open-ended questions that are based
loosely on
the system usability scale
and which is this validated efficient
clear way to gather
reliable data about usability
so i'm not specifically going to use
this checklist but i will draw upon it
to create the questions for the
semi-structured interview
um and then using the feedback from
researchers
then i'll create that final iteration of
the guidelines um
which i will of course gather into
manuscript and submit publication
so this is my timeline for completing
all this work um
which my intention now is to complete it
by the fall term 2021
and i've tried to mention my contingency
plans
as appropriate throughout the
presentation um
but of course covet
so um
you know i am a parent of a
pub i have a kid who goes to public
school
a younger kid who goes to public school
um
and would definitely be easier to meet
this timeline if public schools are
reopened
um
and it's possible that if they don't
reopen
uh or they decide not to reopen at the
end of january then
that might slow my progress a lot and
extend this timeline
which isn't really an obstacle that i
have a complete solution for
so
if any of you have
experience working with kids with autism
and you really want to babysit please
hit me up
i'm totally open to that okay
um these are the select references and
also i want to thank
a bunch of people um particularly my doc
which is nicole weiskopf
uh dion chase miguel moreno and michelle
rybar and um
thank you guys for being so generous
with your time and expertise i'm also
the co-authors on the first manuscript i
worked on
uh dr aaron trimble and dr bethany
collins here in pulmonology ohsu
and all of the
really graciously helpful staff at dmice
who've been so supportive of me in like
a million different ways um particularly
today and dr andrea ilk and lynn schwabe
um and
thank you to my family for allowing me
to neglect them so i could do this um
and thank you to my fellow students for
keeping me sane i appreciate that
okay so
can now
stop sharing
and address any questions you might have
there we go
actually lily this is bill um great
great talk and and um i know
um this time has been challenging for
you and and also um
other students and faculty who have um
young children so um
we
we um
appreciate that that you've continued to
make progress um could you actually put
your specific where the slide that has
the three aims back up i just have a
question
let me
get to that
[Music]
so
is it
[Music]
are you sharing
oh there we go okay sorry
right this one
maybe the one that lists the text of the
three aims
yes okay this one
there we go
yeah okay
um
you know i i wonder um
i know part of it is i'm
i don't know if you've discussed this
with your committee i i'm not crazy
about the word checklist kind of coming
out of a
dissertation that's more i think a
matter of style
um but you know it makes me wonder
though you know you know here you are
dealing with um you know people's data
sets and and how they can hopefully make
their data sets better whether there are
any
um you know data science methods you
know tools that um could be developed
that
that helped the process along rather
than
just for them to have a checklist and
i'm kind of thinking out loud here i
mean i'd have to think this really
through
but almost to the um
standpoint of um
you know
is there some kind of uh i don't know
tool that people could um
run on their data and they did it
different iterations of their data like
you actually showed in aim two that's
sexy when i wanted to get the three
games back up um you know whether there
might be something there that would um
you know provide um you know people with
social determinants data
more than just a checklist but but you
know maybe a tool to help them um
determine what's the best way to analyze
their data and any kind of
transformations they're making to it
you know whether those are
beneficial or not
i'm i'm thinking out loud here so i'm
but i'm just wondering those sorts of
things
yeah i i
agree i think that's a really good idea
like some sort of like tool in python or
something that i could develop
is that what you had in mind
i i think something um along those lines
um
you know if it's even feasible but um
you know i'm just thinking of the kind
of value that um
um
you know as as i've said in in other
presentations you know we
we we always hope that that informatics
dissertations you know somehow develop
new methods um you know in addition to
you know findings and so forth so
um i don't know it's just something to
think about with with yourself and your
committee
yeah no i think it's a good idea um i
guess i found like a lot of those
tools you have to keep
updating them right if you
engineer them if you engineer the
software um
and so i wanted something that was maybe
a little uh
last i guess have a longer shelf life so
that was one
thought for why i wanted to do it this
way and the other way is uh the other
reason is that
you know
in the future once i've graduated to
apply for
another award or a grant
where i could use this and say like okay
my intention is to use this for this
work to develop
some specific tool
right and then that would be the basis
of my grant application
um
some kind of you know
k award type
situation
um so that's another thought too
initially i was calling these like
guidelines or recommendations um
but you know
it was pointed out to me like
do i really
have the kind of
experience as a researcher yet to be
like the
person who can
um
put forth guidelines and i was like well
that's a fair criticism so i kind of
downgraded it from guidelines to a
checklist which i felt was more
um
was more reasonable i guess or was
given my level of experience
um
but you know if there's
a format that other people um either in
this
presentation
think would work better i would totally
be willing to do that too
sure i mean we can let them weigh in or
other people might have other questions
see there's a few in the chat
yeah
let me see if i can do there
okay
data cleaning flow chart
yeah so
yeah that's kind of what i was trying to
do with aim2
um
to answer
aaron's point um adam
like
aim2 to do multiverse analysis that's a
good way to put it
like
this is what this would do this is what
this would do
um
at this point for aim 1 2 what's your
hunter hypothesis about what you would
find
um so
that's a good question one of the things
i think might show up is that
address data will be particularly
problematic because
a lot of those
linked data sets that are used so
frequently in social determinants
research
are so heavily dependent on address data
right you can't do the linkage if you
don't have
a patient's address or zip code and if
you don't um or if the the address or
zip code you have is inaccurate then the
whole thing is just wrong
um
and so that's kind of one of my
hypotheses is that um is the case
um also
you know as we're doing more and more
health equity research um that
ethnograph uh
sorry the information about
race and ethnicity tends to be is
becoming more and more important however
it's generally
incomplete except for federally
qualified health centers who are
required now to collect it but i think
um at ohsu
i asked
someone from
oaktree and i believe it was somewhere
around like
present
which is not really great right so a lot
of
the preliminary work i've done is like
on how
to improve
those particular variables and get
either more accurate more granular or
more complete
information about race and ethnicity
yeah i think um you know i think adam um
you know makes some great points about
you know really what what this is about
is what what you're expecting to find
and then that will um
guide um
you know whatever recommendations or or
guidelines i i don't think a
phd student should necessarily um you
know shy away from developing guidelines
um
whatever you want to call them um and
and you know maybe nicole's point about
extending um
existing tools
um
you know basic you know
you know maybe based on those kinds of
um
paradigms
yeah and i i guess i also liked
checklist because it seems more flexible
whereas guidelines seems a little bit um
more based on
guidelines seem like something that
would vary a great deal from data set to
data set whereas a checklist is kind of
something that you can use more broadly
across a number of different situations
um but yeah i like
i like christine's
uh
suggestion too about maybe calling it a
framework framework is good too has a
lot of the same flexibility
um but is a little bit more
i don't know
uh official something academic sounding
um
let me see if there's anything else i
missed here
this is adam i just wanted to read back
one of the things you said one of the
things i think is interesting about what
you first said of address information
being so critical is that seems like
this really valuable piece of linking
information
that you have if you have address or zip
code you can link that to other things
like
uh percent free or reduced lunch or
other social determinants of health
so i wonder you just going forward what
other those linking variables
are so valuable um in social
determinants of health research and that
seems to me
uh one aspect of data cleaner equality
that is maybe not unique to social
determinants of health but is really
prevalent of needing to use these
linking variables to then attach to
other data sets so i thought that was
really insightful in what you're saying
yeah and and
to some degree the fact that we used
address
as the primary way to link people's data
is kind of an artifact of
the
privacy regulations in the united states
for example um
like in
the uk
they can
be
a lot
more they can make those linkages a lot
more based on individuals because they
don't have those same privacy
regulations and they have this
nationalized healthcare system
which they can you know they have
everybody's data um
and so yeah
but here in the u.s address data is
particularly important so
um things like how granular that data is
for example with the publicly available
data sets
through the national
cove
collaborative collaboration or whatever
all this letter stands for um those data
sets like
i believe they do include
um
they're publicly available so they
include zip code but it's been
anonymized somehow right so that really
affects what you can reliably
link to that particular data set
um or how granular that information is
like do you have
the person's
zip
code or do you have their zip plus four
or do you have like what's called the
zcta like you can get different levels
of granularity based on that right
sometimes you can only do it by county
which is
not very granular at all and sometimes
you can do it by
just you know
places that are in a couple block radius
which is far more accurate
so yeah address data is particularly
important
thank you for that comment adam i
appreciate it
all right anybody else have
the very last question in the box from
the esteemed homer chen
is there an agreed-upon set of discrete
variables for social determinants
you may want to really nail down the
definitions early on
yeah so that's a good point so the
answer is like not really
um there are some things that pretty
much everybody puts in there but
sometimes people don't put in
environmental
uh factors for example when they just
call them social behavioral
um
and sometimes
they include the behavioral aspects so
sometimes it might include like smoking
um
so there are
maybe like 70 percent of the
things in there
um like
race ethnicity for example
are um pretty much always considered
social determinants and then there are
some other things that include the
behavioral factors and the environmental
factors that not everybody includes in
the definition
that can vary a little bit
more
you know speaking of addresses i just
put a link there's a new project some of
you may have heard about this that onc
is starting
um
because we don't standardize addresses
in the u.s which and because we don't
have a national
uh health identifier you know we
oftentimes heavily rely on address
um for linking patients and and other
things like some of the social
determinants things that you're doing
so i don't know if there's anything of
interest there
um
yeah and what we do have is based on
is from the postal service right which
is intended to deliver mail and it's not
really
it's not really meant for research um
and so a lot of the work that the census
has done is actually a little bit better
because they do kind of use it their
intention is to gather
data but for example when i was working
with the data set the cystic fibrosis
dataset um i found
maybe
like 80 out of the 13 000 data elements
i had
weren't matching up and
it took me a couple days but i traced it
back to the fact that
um the u.s postal service had added
a zip code to beaverton like six years
ago
and so
the
addresses that i had weren't matching up
with the environmental data for that
reason and i had to like go back and
correct
each in the spreadsheet which is pretty
time consuming um so anytime right that
the postal service decides oh we need
more zip codes or we're going to take
off the zip code or we're going to split
the zip code in half like that kind of
messes up that can cause havoc with your
research
um and they're not making those
decisions based on what researchers need
they're basing it on what
their postal carriers need
yes i mean those and you know so those
are the kinds of things it seems you
know again i'm i'm not an expert in this
area um but um you know those are the
kinds of things that might throw off um
social determinants research if if the
postal service
to you know slice and dice zip codes um
you know that actually happened years
ago with you know ohsu used to be in a
different zip code and it's probably
been about 15 years but
i don't know that it messed up anyone's
data but i do remember it was a big
thing because all of a sudden we're
supposed to be using a different zip
code anyways we're we're just about out
of time i i i notice eric wecker makes a
good point as well
another
thing that people are realizing is an
important social determinant of health
is access to
broadband internet and you know we've
seen the challenges
in patient care for people who don't
have that access
um does anyone have any
last questions or comments
um if not um
oh i'm sorry
oh sorry this is nicole i just wanted to
one last point that i did want to
emphasize is that lily is also proposing
that she is going to extend an existing
conceptual framework
for data quality assessment
so
the checklist would be potentially an
operationalization or one deliverable
but there is the higher level extension
of the con framework also
yes
and okay
um
the
ramundo kind of framework around data
cleaning also so i'm trying to draw upon
existing work where it's available and
things that have been validated around
for a long time
yeah that
that sounds great you may want to
emphasize that that a little bit more um
but okay well um i see that people are
already starting to depart um so thank
you lily and um we'll look forward to
hearing uh about your progress during
your uh dissertation work and then at
some point in the future we'll look
forward to having you back to defend it
maybe we'll all be back in the office
then you can do it in the big theater
that would be great
okay taking all of you guys again too
great
okay take care everyone bye-bye
okay let me pull up
a
document in word so i can write down
all of this and
also whatever you guys give me sorry i
keep using the work guys i'm trying not
to use the word guys
i struggle with that as well
but when i'm like
nervous and anxious it comes out
okay uh italia is that
someone you want
i don't think so
i'm going to expel italia
thank you
sorry italia you're a corolla andrea i
know i love it
who's got host i have hosts i can't get
rid of her oh
um lily i'm gonna make you i don't even
know if i can make you host lily let's
see all i see is people insights chat
and make presenter
like
options but it doesn't sound like she's
still
she's not on i'm sure she just turned it
on so um diane set up this meeting
initially so i don't have a chance to
move anybody over to host so i'm just
going to leave the meeting
i won't end it and then you guys can end
it when you're done
okay
sound good
and then natalia is not clearly not on
so she should when she gets back on
she'll probably leave also
wait
oh wait there's a host key
can you
pull it to yourself
it says no it requests a key request the
key
yeah anybody know what the key is no
no
okay
oh well hopefully all right good luck
thank you
okay
so
feedback further questions
i thought you did a great presentation
well done
thank you
i guess one thing i'm wondering to
nicole
um
do you since you're more
experienced with n3c
group data quality and social
determinants group do you have any like
kind of
things i could fill in for details about
how to
use
how to work the um
how to use that group to kind of create
the iteration
yeah
it's a good question i'm not sure the
best language to describe that and so
it's a bit of background for michelle
and
diane so the social determinants group
they've just explicitly started what
they're calling their quality assurance
step
and they're basically saying well we've
got all of these publicly available data
sets that have been linked into the
actual clinical data and people are
ready to start asking and answering
questions using those data but there's
been no data quality assessment done
um
and
you know increasingly there's an
awareness that there are going to be
substantial issues that we really need
to at least
understand um
so cherise madloch brown who's leading
the group is like okay so who wants to
be in this meeting and i was like me and
also lily who's not here sorry lily
so the hope is that we're going to
develop this pipeline that then
the people in the group can apply
so there's going to be this kind of
built-in iterative process to see like
how well does this pipeline actually
work and what kinds of problems are
being identified
i don't know how best to capture that
process
from
um
kind of a formal standpoint in a
proposal or something along those lines
yeah that's not necessarily
yeah i guess there isn't
a lot of structure to it right now i
mean
it's kind of evolving or the structure
is there are people who are very good at
describing this kind of process in a
formal way though so i'm sure
there's got to be something there
yeah dion you know a lot about
qualitative methods
i'm wondering if something from like
software engineering
okay so i'm sorry like there's a
question particular to
the the culvert project the nc3 project
yeah and like um
there's kind of three iterations of
whatever i'm gonna call it checklist
framework
um or tools
and one of them is to like apply it to
the covid
social determinants
public data set that
nicole and i have been
working on
and
to
iterate based on the experience with
that but
you know i feel like that
i think you're gonna have a couple
issues one is the simply time
frame the covered process is going to
want to work really fast yeah that's a
good point here and they're not going to
have time for for you to wait and do a
literature search be really blunt
so that's going to be something that's
done
almost on a naive basis if you will
naive so okay
yeah that'd be jack during but it sounds
nice
it's uh but but but you know you nicole
been thinking about it so you could you
could
you know one thing you could do is
simply say okay
um
let's lay out a process of here or here
are being just based on what we know
and please guys
understand this is a work in process
but here are
what we would anticipate based upon what
we've seen thus far
as being your your top 10 list
of data quality issues you can think
about
okay and you can refer back to your
frameworks if you want but then i want
what i would do if i was you i take a
look at their data sets and say and so
here's where they're likely to pop up in
your data set
you know if you're looking at
non-conformance looking at you know uh
completeness that type of thing and i
think you could probably talk fairly
articulately about that
okay and say okay and so then say and
then here are different ways you might
address those problems
and
now this is this is significantly
changing the scope and direction of your
project though just you know that
but i think it's on the other hand i
think it's a wonderful opportunity
second thing
i would say is once you do that
then you circulate to the group and you
have like one-on-ones
to the group and probably of people
outside the data quality to say okay
here is are some of the things we're
thinking about
how does this meet with your you know
your expectations
that make sense
so basically you do a straw person you
get you get input from that and based
upon that you refine the process for the
data data munching if you will
you know like you know first step one
maybe just gross data visualization
let's let's simply say you know you know
uh you know here the fields we have you
know here's the we're missing
is this a problem or not you know if
we're missing
seven percent of the data
probably don't even have enough to
impute
okay and that's actually uh so that's
that's kind of one way you could work
with them but it it is a change in your
direction
so just take that into account
second you know okay but that's yeah
it's just it sounds like a fantastic
opportunity but it it will be it's a
different project and i think
for my part i think obviously the kohl's
we're going to support that but let's
let's figure out what that is first
yeah i'm very concerned about your
timeline really we'll get to that
a little bit
uh so
if
if we could take
having said that this this meets the
requirements for a proposal i think
uh for meeting the proposal
headline but i would like to see this
reworked a little bit just so we've got
a better contract
something that's going to be more
deliverable for you
okay
and this is partially my fault um
because
it's yeah it is
because this opportunity with the n3c
group arrows
last minute um right
but it just seems like it fulfills the
purpose of the previous aim three so
well and it is a really good opportunity
but you're right it changes the
dependencies in the proposal somewhat
because it's something um that's going
to start happening
if you if you're if you're going to do
start this next july
they're going to the ship's going to be
gone
yeah it's these things are going to be
happening more in parallel and lily has
already completed the majority of aim
two right
yes
uh yes and no
i mean yes i've already done all the
data cleaning and i tried to document it
as i went
um
but it isn't like an
into anything that's like
okay but for two what i've seen is
basically you're looking at pairwise
exclusion
pairwise exclusion
you mean like basically if the data is
is bad you throw it out
okay and that's not necessary you know
you've gone on your committee miguel
mourinho
who is actually a national expert in
imputation
so i think you have to be able to talk
in into
also about the effects of using
different imputation methods
and what the opportunities and pitfalls
of doing amputation are
okay
that's actually that's a pretty big i
mean i i spent a lot of time on my
uh my dissertation going around around
the circle of dating participation
but basically i could make the data
saying that i wanted to if i computed it
right
that's one of the more um
esoteric
and in subjective things too so maybe
that was why i didn't emphasize it
because i did do a little bit of
imputation and i can
like show you you're gonna have to
address it you're gonna have to address
it yeah i think i think it's it's it's
it is a major thing when you talk about
data cleaning especially with the fda uh
aids that's
yeah because excluding
excluding the incomplete data
is definitely an a health equity issue
and so not being you know so not being
able to impute it is
i think is an issue yeah so for example
um
[Music]
the part that i imputed was oh
um
[Music]
well you said 152 all those could be
inferred from values elsewhere
yeah right so insurance
status and also even the address right
like sometimes
um
oh i know whether there was something
that isn't in here but like whether or
not that person was
the patient had been
active in the program on particular
years right so for example um
you couldn't really tell
the registry will confirm people's
address
annually however you can't tell if the
person wasn't a patient that year or
what happened was that they just didn't
answer their phone and so the registry
was unable to confirm right okay
so
for a lot of the times if i you know if
somebody was
a patient all
for every other nine out of the ten
years and then in the middle they
weren't um they weren't showing up then
what i did was just assume or impute
that they
they got missed misfire
um
okay
um yeah so that's just a comment and so
yeah so so what i would hope you would
do is you'd be looking at what happens
for data if you've imputed or not and
how that changes the results you're
looking at the multiverse
general let's see desperately
um
can we go back to aim one and i'm sorry
i talk too much
no you're not talking too much okay
okay aim one
okay to what degree
is this a broad framework that will
include
data quality issues
within an ehr only
within an er heroin when matched with
address data
or with an ehr matching other for
example uh registry data
so what what's your limitation here lily
and that's just
for the ascent you know and my
[Music]
put you know and think about it also in
terms of what you can do before the cub
but some at some point you've got to be
able to tell us
what
if you're doing the whole field
i would say you're over ambitious
with all the scope you've got here
but i'd also think about how you want to
tailor it giving your access now to the
the covet data
and so you know
and yeah and
so i'm just saying let's think about it
and make sure that it's trying to make
it doable
and
maybe even a lose part of the
honestly i would be willing
if you if you took and you really
expanded your work with with the covet
team
i think that plus doing your own work
plus doing the lit search
is probably enough for for a good
article and maybe you don't have to go
to the best practices how's that for any
rather than a checklist
oh okay
that's i don't know what i don't know
what other committee members think but
that's i just think that there's
doing
two significant projects
it is
plus the library is is a lot of work
and definitely
you think about it as setting you up for
getting a you know your initial k grant
as being using that work to develop the
the your best practices
so that's i've just
as i said i'm really worried about the
timeline
so so for for aim one what i would
really like you to do
is to specify very clearly
what
combinations of data sets you're going
to be looking at
mm-hmm okay or what types of data
elements
and i'm and it i'm i'm not
unwilling to support anyone you want but
recognize that
you know the broader your your your net
the more time it's going to take
right
i mean initially my thought was to just
make it all um
i don't need an answer now
oh okay but i'm just i'm just saying
but i'm saying i would like
a
different draft and it can be just of
this powerpoint or whatever you want
that specifies
okay a little bit curly what what types
of data elements you're willing to look
at
okay
and that's that's all
michelle i can't hear you
uh i agree with diane about that um
mostly the way i would say it is
my concern is that i think
your copit analysis is going to be a big
part of your work but right now it's
just like a sub-point of aim three
and it seems like
you know especially from what dionne
just said is that
is there a way to make that almost aim2
so it's more of a focus
and then um
i don't know if aim 3 could then be
going back to your work that you already
did with the cystic fibrosis and then
applying what you did
there i mean i don't know how much
you're going to say
what you've done
with the air quality and the cystic
fibrosis and forms what you did with
covid or vice versa or if you could use
that data set as an example of showing
lessons learned from your cova data
analysis how they apply to a different
data set do what i'm saying because
right now it seems like
you're doing
the focus is on the cystic fibrosis and
then you're kind of seeing like how does
this work with covid does it make sense
to shift the focus the other way if you
anticipate spending most of your time
doing the analysis and data quality of
the cova data set
that's a good
point and especially given that the
coveted
research as dan pointed out is very
timely like it's the timeline is very
tight
[Music]
and so it makes more sense to make sure
about that instead
yeah and the other thing just from
my experience with research is that at
least for me i do much better and i'm
much far
far more successful when i'm working
with other people in a group on a
project and you're getting
input from these other people and i
think that that's going to make that
work
go faster and be easier so the more that
can be kind of the emphasis of your work
i think the more
successful you're going to be and
potentially the more on time you're
going to be
i agree and i feel like that was a huge
part of the motivation actually for
getting involved in the n3c for agreeing
to do
you know what um nicole suggested is
like wow i get access to this whole team
of people and they'll have momentum and
they'll have expertise and they'll be
able to give me feedback on a regular
basis
yes it's like enormously appealing in
addition to the fact that covets just
like interesting and
um
and it's important but i think the
bigger appeal is that having that team
of people
so that is another good reason to make
the mc3 thing part of the m2 rather than
game three right and from my standpoint
you could do it a bunch of different
ways you you know
i think you do need to do a lit search
sorry that's just
it's it's part of the suffering you have
to do
um
but you could
you could do it on lip search in your
two ames or case study one and case
study two in case study one i would put
up to be your covent work
and then go get them clean up
you could do it to do
a lip search case
case study which is the covet and then
do
it in the cobot process try drafting
some internally some guidelines and then
take that to a panel and just forget
going back and re-analyzing your data
or you could do you know so you could do
two case studies you could do
as it is you could have you know
you've got
four parts i think
pick two or three
[Music]
okay and i'm sorry part one is
non-negotiable
and i don't
yeah
any one of them was for me it would be
great
i think i think the cloven is going to
be much
for the same it's going to be a much
better
platform to work for them in the
future it's going to be
um
as my money in banking for i had a swiss
money and banking professor
they told me that it would be a
memorical experience yeah america
just the fact that it's real time you're
working with with
some great data sources that you
probably wouldn't access before and
you're going to have people you can get
to give you immediate feedback and that
will you're going to be on the firing
line
yeah have fun
i also have to say as far as like
guidelines go
you know the end product for my
dissertation was a conceptual framework
and a guideline and i
i i sweat blood over that guideline and
i don't think anyone has ever used it
people like the conceptual framework
they like something they can look at on
a page
um
but that's
that will get a lot more use probably
and unfortunately than something like a
guideline a lot of the time
i'm afraid bill's right checklist is a
dirty word to some people
i was a little peeved with that comment
well
yeah but have you ever talked to a
surgeon about a checklist
yeah i just think about things like you
know
like the consort guideline and all the
other equator network reporting
guidelines when really what it boils
down to is a checklist and they call it
a checklist
but
it's a semantics issue
it's bill
gawande ruin it for everyone
probably
hey he's gonna be he's gonna be inviting
his team
oh really i didn't know that
he's one of the healthcare advisors for
the transition right now okay
answer the question what's his role
going to be ongoing
okay so pick two or three
um to make this timeline more doable
um definitely make the let's search part
of it and
we all feel there's a really strong case
for making mc3
part of it
okay and let's can we talk about the
manuscript writing process because
we've got
almost a real-time manuscript writing
process
which is takes a lot of discipline
and
nicole were you able to write yours on a
real-time basis
yes
yeah for the most part okay i'm glad you
could i mean it was that was really hard
it's it's hard yeah well you are also
doing a lot of qualitative analysis
which is
so time consuming
right
yeah no
yeah so it's just lack of discipline um
be early honest so but to be serious um
so typically
um the way my committee wanted me to
work on the
with the process was that i would write
my methods
okay
right up right at the beginning so so
the methods would be done
like for lit review the methods would be
actually be done your methods section
would be written on the 24th of december
that makes sense
and that's in the ejection so you'd
actually see your methods write your
method section that guides what you're
going to do and get that out so you get
comments from from your committee at
least at least nicole
and maybe your comedian
at certain points
as you go in and typically it goes it
goes methods
okay then you do your analysis and you
write up your analysis
analysis section
and then you can discuss and conclusions
of the abstract all together
but you want to take it but you want to
take in and you basically you need to
get the
get those done and
see question order but definitely get
your methods done before you start you
might even do the background
back background you could do back to
excel background and methods you could
do book first
okay
okay then do uh
analysis discussion
and then you're you're typically what
happened was we would this will read it
we'd write the
uh conclusion and the
uh abstract at the end is that the
process you used nicole or
michelle
um
i found it varied somewhat with the
methods you know i tried to have the
methods hammered out beforehand
definitely but stuff
changed as i went along yeah right
but you needed to have a draft that you
had starting out
if you three
if you're gonna need a six-week or a
brother a
yeah if you're gonna be a nine-week
framer for getting this done
it's gonna take that
well that's gonna be really key to you
you're getting this thing done
and remember that it's not just the time
for you to write it's the time for
nicole and
maybe at some points michelle and i and
miguel to review what you're doing
and so that's which is it's frustrating
it's going to be frustrating it's health
but that's kind of the way you got to do
it
because the last thing you want to do is
hand somebody a written a final paper
and say this is it and you go
uh lily i think you missed something at
the beginning
mm-hmm right
so break so
the extent for me at least they said i
could bring my committee along with me
saved a lot of trouble at the end and
when i didn't it was a real pain
one thing that i have found really
helpful for
staying
on a timeline for writing manuscripts is
applying for conferences
so
if you say that you are going to do a
presentation on x y and z at amia and
you submit a podium abstract and it gets
accepted well you
better get that work done
um within that time span and then i find
the process of going through creating a
slide deck is actually really really
helpful for working out the narrative
um
and it's probably not ideal that i
submit
podium abstracts for things i haven't
finished but i think that's what happens
a lot of the time
and um
i'm sorry go ahead nickel okay yeah i
don't know if you saw but diane also
sent out an email that you have until
june of 2022 to get your work done so
your timeline can be expanded a little
bit
okay
okay and the next conference coming up
there's a clinical informatics
conference coming up may
18th to 20th and the the submission
deadline is january 5th
yeah i think that was just extended so
yeah that was my first thought is
go for that one
is that a good event uh venue for
presenting a lit review or is that
would you be presenting more of your
initial
data from uh the covid
uh
work
good question
um
i don't know what do you guys think
i think you've got a much higher chance
of acceptance if you talked about
um this will be a real-time report on
the process of
developing quality
metrics for data to be used in carbon
research
okay
i don't know if the clinical informatics
conference is going to be the best venue
though
what do you think
um
what do you think would be better
okay so here is
the objectives for these for this
conference is to apply evidence or
experience based models of informatics
processes to improve health care
i think this kind of fits that
leverage schools yeah
um
okay
identify relevant metals public and
population health and domestic
strategies for health issues
might be applicable
um
identify diversity equity inclusion
issues through the lens of clinical
dramatics
is there
um
something else that you a different
format that you feel would work you said
maybe
the ania
one wouldn't be the best is there
something else that would work
better in your opinion nicole
so the one that you're talking about is
the clinical informatics one
yeah sorry okay
um
i mean my initial thought was that a
summit
or
annual symposium would be a better fit
but based on what dionne was just saying
i could be totally off base on that
i mean my view is just that the clinical
informatics one is more focused on
healthcare delivery
um and very patient focused
okay
i'm writing all this down i wonder if
they're going to be any
sessions for
summits
and michelle
you've been quiet do you have any uh
feedback or ideas or
yeah i'm just looking here and i'm
seeing
nicole's pictures on the um
scientific
program committee for
uh for the summit i should know i should
know about late breaking sessions but i
don't
um yeah i've never gone to summit so i'm
not very familiar with it uh i was just
wondering i mean i know that the
deadlines for the annual symposium are
in march
i don't know if having that extra time
would give you
more substance in either a
podium
presentation you know abstract or
even if you might have enough for like a
preliminary paper
um that you could write up so the
advantage of that would be you would
have a
you know a broader focused conference
and maybe a little bit more time for
a more developed
submission
yeah
and i think that could be a really good
um place to submit the actual paper for
what's currently aimed to
also
okay
what do you guys think
actually i'm just looking at
the ieee stuff
and they have something that we the
deadline submission is the 15th november
data science and smart healthcare
challenges and opportunities
looking at how they integrate social
theater so that's the look for that to
come out
so this whole 18th of november though
it says passed yeah oh okay
well passed
too bad yeah but it looks like there's
there's a bunch of stuff
yeah
that i would look for in in the ieees
just tons of stuff going on there
i don't know if it's any good but
there's a lot of stuff
okay
yeah i'm gonna need to run i'm afraid
and i apologize oh yeah but i i think
this was very good lily um
and yeah you're curious yeah you're
really coming along
okay thank you
incorporate that feedback and
yeah it's not a straight line i'm sorry
it never is that's okay
thank you you take care thanks diane
thank you i'm saying goodbye to my
grandson bye bye
[Music]
okay anything else i need to
put in here any other revisions i need
to
make or ideas
one other comment i had about was you
know depending on how you decide you
want to implement this framework and i
don't know how much of this is important
to
to really hammer out right now in the
proposal stage but
um
you know when you get feedback from
experts and you're using
you know if you're using questions from
like the the usability scale
you know that that's really intended to
be for a very specific use case
so you might want to think about that so
if you are working with experts on
this n3c data
and you're coming up with this stuff
maybe trying to figure out in the
process of doing it how you make that
iterative and how you get that feedback
and getting that figure to be as
targeted as you possibly can
if you decide that you want to apply it
to a second use case let's say the
cystic fibrosis data
um
then you'd probably want to get specific
feedback from other people on that use
case as well
but i don't know if you can just hand
someone
like a framework and and ask them like
how usable you think this would be
without giving them a specific
data set or task does that make sense
so it might if you're looking for that
level of feedback it might be more
useful to think about how you might
incorporate that into your overall
process of working with people on this
data as you go
uh and i'm not exactly sure how that i
am having trouble kind of wrapping my
head around exactly how you do that
but um that would be my only
um
comment about that i'm not sure i'd have
it sort of
so separate because i think that's going
to be a real challenge
that's a good point
um i mean one option in terms of trying
to
find the right methodology and
terminology for that iterative process
would be looking at software engineering
methods
and i dropped in a wikipedia link
um
because a lot of the time the language
that you'll see around that like agile
spiral method etc have been applied
pretty broadly beyond just software
development and it might work in this
kind of setting
um
and the other
thing that's possible would be just
talking to people who have a strong
history of being successful with that
kind of approach
um
because it's
there are ways to write it so that it
sounds horrible instead of ad hoc
and i'm not personally super great at
that but
i'm thinking um
you know dave door is pretty good at
that kind of thing adam wilcox
um and i would even since
the talk that sue bakken gave recently
um
yeah
there's supposed to be a video cast
that's not available
what i checked last it wasn't available
it might be now um but they used like a
very
iterative process for developing um
conveying health information to patients
potentially with local health literacy
and
the way she describes it it sounds very
formal and well developed and
comprehensive
um i think a lot of it is just in how
she describes it and then in reality
there is kind of a lot of
goosiness to the actual process
yeah and i don't know i mean because the
way
we usually talk about
this is you know sort of like the
user-centered
design iterative kind of development um
so i don't know if
it makes sense to
think about it as
um
you know first of all you're you're
trying to do this to
analyze and potentially improve i don't
know if you how much
power or ability you're going to have to
improve this n3c data set but you know
you're going to be analyzing this
so but at the same time you
want to make
you know you kind of
you don't just want to like you're not
just doing this because you're you care
about this data you're actually trying
to then
make at the same time sort of a
framework or guidelines or lessons
learned or
flow chart or something like that and so
how that gets
kind of incorporated into it and it's
sort of like this iterative
process of
developing these best practices or this
flow chart or something like that for
tackling
you know social determinants of health
in this case it's for the data in covid
but you're hoping it'd be applicable to
other data sets as well
yeah and i wonder if there's almost like
a very simple um
error
that you could design that would go
along with this tool
or this flowchart or whatever it is as
we're developing it where it's just like
i mean the nice thing is you don't need
to recruit people because people are
going to be
trying to apply these steps
um and say like you know what was the
concept that you were looking at
in which data set or data sets
and
were there parts of this that were
really helpful or parts that were not
helpful or confusing
or were there things that were missing
from this
um
and make it almost more like an issue
tracking thing
[Music]
i like that i like that it's
issue tracking
yeah i think i need to more carefully
consider how it would kind of fit into
the research
workflow
and then
therefore
but i think that's the whole part of
what you're trying to propose right is
that you're trying to
like
look at this from like a
a higher level view as you're doing it
as opposed to just this ad hoc
how do i get my data in
some format that i can use it right
whether i'm
just okay
you know oh i think i'll just impute
here or
you know oh this data's missing i'm just
going to eliminate them right you know
so instead of doing that you're kind of
like
okay
this is my data this is the
characteristic so there's got to be some
kind of characterization that happens i
don't know whether it's using
visualizations too but then when you
come up with these different
issues and there are decisions to be
made you know how do you
kind of
uh enumerate what the options are
and then how do you how
you know
how do you decide between them and it
may be that
you can't definitively say how you know
you can't necessarily come up with rules
depending on what they are right um
but
that's the way i think this would be
helpful i mean from
my perspective you know
doing this kind of stuff this is what i
think would be really helpful is like
being able to
you know kind of go through this
especially you know with respect to this
you know this this data the the social
determinant data um
and
i know this
might sound like potentially like a big
shift in what you had proposed
um
so i mean if you
if it's making you feel uncomfortable
with this change in direction i
definitely want to talk about that
um
but i will also say that even though it
sounds like a big thing with a lot of
moving parts i think in a lot of ways
this will be
easier than what you had proposed for
your aim three
um
because a lot of it is a process that is
already in motion
um
[Music]
so yeah i mean obviously again if
there's anything about it that you're
not comfortable with
like
we want to talk about it but i i do
think that this will make the whole
thing a little bit more feasible in the
long run
yeah and i also think we can talk about
if you want or you can talk about nicole
what makes sense for you to solidify
right now in the proposal
and then
you know and then going ahead you know
then what
you know because at this point we just
want to make sure you have a good sense
of what it is you're going to do and you
have a direction right
but i've been on enough of these
committees to know that
it's
it's more the exception than the rule
that anyone ever follows that to a t
you know things always come up and you
wind up kind of you know this part took
longer so this became more of my focus
and we had to drop this off you know
that kind of thing
so
uh
you know
the first thing is we realized number
one is that this is not like you know
it's not some blood contract that you're
signing up for that you have to do
perfectly the way you say right now
um
and so
you know right it might be helpful to
figure out well what what kind of an
outline do you need right now to kind of
make sure that you're on the right path
and it's going to really reflect the
work that you're doing and the work
that's going to be
the easiest for you to do the ones
getting more motivating that's going to
you know that you're most interested in
um knowing that there's always going to
be things that kind of come up that
might sway
sort of where you wind up going
yeah
to build that
expectation of flexibility in
yeah and i mean again if once you get to
the point of defending your dissertation
if you put up three good aims there
no one's going to be like this isn't
what was in your proposal
now i mean the point of the proposal is
really to make sure you are ready to
move on
um
it's not a contract
well and i will tell you too that when
the aims that you propose for a grant
often aren't exactly what you wind up
doing either the aims you propose for a
grant are what you think your um
the review committee is the most
interested in hearing about it's not
necessarily the work you wind up
actually publishing and doing um
so that's a whole nother can of worms
that you know a dissertation doesn't
have to deal with but um
yeah we just want to make sure you have
a good framework and direction so that
you have
at least you know what you're doing
next week and next month even but the
stuff that's like six or nine months out
maybe isn't as crystal clear
but you've got some idea of where you're
going and you know what your next steps
are
so do you have any questions for us at
this point i know we've taken you for a
long time you might have to go
oh it's okay um
no i don't i think that's all really
helpful feedback and i especially
appreciate like
clarifying the ideas but also like
helping me to make it more
feasible and doable and like something
to make sure i don't
bite off more than i can possibly
do
over the next you know
year or so yeah but i think having the
opportunity to work with the n3c
data is just a really good opportunity
for you i think it's going to be um
good to work with those people but i
also think it's going to be
stuff that's going to be potentially you
know highly desirable to be published
you know so that's going to be something
that um
you know i could tell you from the
aspect of working on data and
ophthalmology that a lot of times i'm
just i get that we don't care
eyeballs yeah who cares
but you know like coveted people care
about right so um
you know i think there's a lot to like
even if it is a little bit of a detour
from what you had originally
maybe thought you were doing
mm-hmm
yeah from the whole like
year that i spent studying
wildfire
and i hesitate to throw that away but it
was valuable in lots of other ways
no but i think you're still going to
have opportunities to draw back on that
it's just trying to figure out how to
do that in a good way
while still moving forward in this other
direction that is a little bit more time
sensitive and or critical and
is potentially going to be more
productive for you
yeah
then maybe i could just use
that wildfire work as like okay i'll get
published in a field that's kind of
difficult
adjacent and that's like
it's it's sort of like preliminary work
i mean it's sort of demonstrating well
i've done this before i've seen these
issues this is what's come up now i'm
applying it to this new
kind of yeah yeah
and i still think if you can
get that published like the informatics
view of that and i do think aimee might
be a really good place for that
that's your second name
um
michelle what are the
the big next steps because it sounds
like deanna does want some
updated draft of either the proposal or
the slides
uh for me i don't really care which one
it is um
you know i just think having a
a good kind of outline of
the aims
and
um kind of reflecting where you think
your focus is going to be over the next
you know
year
um i do like her um
wanting you to put some structure around
the
lip review and trying to get that done
but i do think if if you decide that the
n3c is kind of an um
important issue for you it might be
and i you know it's
i don't know how much of that
like it's going to constrain your lit
search versus if you weren't doing it
for that application i don't know i mean
i'm having a hard time kind of thinking
that through like what your lit review
would do when if you're
trying to focus on cova data i'm not
sure it's going to change much because
you're still talking about
you know social determinant i'll try to
link to potentially public so you know
like that stuff's still there so i i
don't know
um
but i also don't know
kind of what the m3c timeline is and
what you're working on with them right
now and so how to balance those two out
like how do you get the lit review done
while you're
right with the focus now what you're
doing with that group
so i think
trying to you know kind of figure out a
plan for how to do both of those maybe
consecutively might be helpful not
necessarily in the proposal but just for
yourself
um
thinking that through
so maybe like an updated timeline and
then updated
just like one page summary of the aims
and the components do you think that
would be
i think so
yeah
how does that
sound i can do that
okay
um
it's the end of the term and i have to
do
grading for
the other for scientific writing
um so i could probably
have that by like the end of the next
week
yeah and i think technically you have
until the 31st to get the proposal done
and signed off on within
um
this term
so
um i'll send an email after this to
dionne and just make sure she would be
she would be okay accepting like an
updated timeline in that one page
description
[Music]
um
but
yeah i i think that should be sufficient
so i'll just make sure
and then i think we've got a little bit
of flexibility in terms of when you
would need to get that to us
so you can prioritize the grading
and i do think it's worth thinking about
um
where or how you're going to publish
some of the work with the m3c stuff and
maybe that's already sort of in the
works like you're already
and i don't know how soon that's going
to happen but
given
the timeliness of the topic i would
kind of try and figure that out like is
that going to be
a conference is that going to be
you know conference abstract conference
paper or is it going to be a journal
article
do you think that's going to be because
i think that's going to help you kind of
figure out
how to prioritize all of this
it's a good point and i think cherise is
good at that kind of strategizing
so
we can also talk to her
guys one of my cats is super stoned
right now because we had to take her to
the vet
and all she wants to do is sleep and the
kitten is like chewing on her face and
it's really cute and also really sad
stoned on what
gabapentin
oh
a lot of vets recommend it before a
visit for cats that gets stressed out
oh she's just chill
she's really
pretty sloppy
wait can you see can you point her
yeah see let me you guys see this
that's pretty cute
she would usually just have him
pinned
and she just she can't
oh i miss kitties
they're pretty great
so i apologize yes now i love it
okay i can do
that all of those things like the
updated timeline updated one page
summary of the aims and components and
then maybe a little bit
of more detail about where and how to
publish the n3c stuff into um
you know
what i'm going to apply for and steps
that will help me use those deadlines in
the way that cole talked about earlier
okay
i can do that
all right and i'm gonna i'm drafting
this email to dionne right now um do you
want me to see see you on that lily or
would you rather i loop you in
afterwards
um you can see me that would be helpful
okay
all right that sounds good and again
lily great job i think people were
into your presentation and your topic
yeah i'm glad i got questions and there
was a pretty good chat
yeah and just seeing it develop over the
last several months i mean it's really
impressive
i think
especially given everything going on
right now yes
i wish i had work like that to show for
this past several months
all right well i hope you get a chance
to relax a little bit today
yes
i will try with all the grading relax
with grading um i really appreciate
all your time and feedback and support
too so thank you guys
all right good luck bye now thanks bye
you